we're going to begin this hour with new
information about the rollout of the
coronavirus vaccine
very encouraging millions of doses could
reach americans before christmas
and that's according to a federal
document obtained by cbs news
the first shots of pfizer's vaccine
could be ready for patients as soon as
december 15th that's just two weeks from
today
modernist vaccine would be available
starting december
22nd both companies are waiting for
emergency authorization from the fda
more than 96 000 people are currently
hospitalized with the coronavirus
nationwide
in the heartbeat midwest the state of
ohio is reporting more than 5 000
current hospitalizations
that is a 200 percent increase just
since november
1st and only on cbs this morning we are
joined now by ohio governor mike dewine
governor dewine good morning to you
every state in america right now is
finalizing a plan to receive
and distribute the very first batch of
coronavirus vaccines
what can you tell us about the plant in
ohio who's going to get it first and how
are you going to get it to them
well first of all this is just great
news we had a call yesterday
with the vice president dr fauci
described this as a
extraordinary outcome and so we're very
very happy it can't come
uh too soon enough we have over 5000
people
in our hospitals now of coba so
it's it's coming and uh you know we're
excited about it
um you know the first responders uh
are first-line nurses first-line doctors
uh those are individuals who clearly
clearly need to get it
are people in our nursing homes who are
the most vulnerable so
you know i think in everybody's first
tier those are the people that are in
the first tier
secretary azar yesterday told us that
governors are air traffic controllers in
other words
you're going to be telling the federal
government which hospital which pharmacy
to send the vaccine do you have those
hospitals in mind and do you have the
resources there
to actually receive the thing keep it
cold and give it to people
yeah we do we've already identified the
10 places uh
in ohio the hospitals uh we're
going to identify in the next several
days for the federal government all the
other places where the shipments are
supposed to be made
for the smaller counties we may actually
break those out and our national guard
may be involved in getting those out as
well so we're
we're moving along and we're we're
excited you know that
december 15th date uh just can't come
soon enough we're very excited about it
and very happy about it it's absolutely
exciting it's also
tricky and the stakes are are high at
one point robert redford the
cdc chief said that six billion dollars
would be needed by the states to
facilitate this distribution but only a
couple hundred million had been
have been put out there you have all the
money you need to pay the people you
need to to get these vaccines
everywhere in the state no we do not but
we're going to get it out uh one way or
the other we have the ability to do that
what we would like of course is a is a
bill from congress uh
you know you carried a story this
morning about negotiations continuing on
and
you know i'm still hopeful that
democrats and republicans and the
president can all get together
uh and get a bill passed because we we
really need that we need to be able to
roll the money over for example that's
already been
been sent out uh we need the flexibility
there
our local governments need some money
our schools need money so
help me understand much like a bill if
you if you don't have the money
to pay the people to distribute the
vaccine how are you going to do it
we're going to do it i mean we have
cares act dollars that we can use we
also have
you know we're going to do whatever we
have to do to get it done
but the bigger picture i think is that
congress does need to pass another bill
for
for many many reasons and i'm hopeful
that that will happen
governor dwight no no no one should ohio
should think that if congress doesn't
pass a bill we're not going to get this
out though i will make that very clear
we will get it out and we'll start the
shots
just as soon as we get it there's a lot
of skepticism
in some parts of the country about the
vaccine it's safety whether people will
be willing to take it that's a big
obstacle
what's your plan in the state of ohio to
convince skeptical populations that this
is a good thing
well i think the most important thing is
is what
medical doctors say and you know one of
the things that we've tried to do
is throughout the pandemic particularly
in the last month or so is to have
frontline nurses and doctors
talking directly to the people of the
state i think they're probably more
believable than
the governor and other politicians so
that's who's going to be
talking to the people about this because
you know as dr fauci pointed out
yesterday
you know everything has been followed
the normal
the protocol it's been quick but
there's no shortcuts that have been
taken and that people will be able to
feel confident that they can take these
these
this vaccine and i think that message
though
comes not from politicians that message
comes from
doctors and medical experts who who
understand
what went on in regard to the
development of this vaccine i think
those facts are going to come out more
in the next several weeks
i hope people hear them governor dewine
i have to ask you about the impeachment
articles filed officially against you
yesterday
accusing you of callous disregard uh for
the businesses and the people affected
by the restrictions you've passed
in an effort to save lives what's your
response
to those articles well look it's four
member
four members of the general assembly
they introduced a resolution before to
have me impeached i guess they have a
right to go and file anything they want
to
but you know we're going to stay focused
on what we have to do
as you pointed out we're being hit very
very hard but governor this is this is a
big this is not a small
issue it's tied to vaccine acceptance
it's tied to wearing masks
it's tied to whatever the next stage is
for for you in in terms of public health
and prevention
um these people think you don't care
about them and they're accusing you of
disregard i mean what's your message to
those politicians but also the people
who follow them
well what i said yesterday in our press
conference when i got that question
was they should talk to the first line
nurses we had four nurses yesterday on
our press conference it was
gut-wrenching to listen to them when
they described
how it is when someone is dying of covet
how it is when someone cannot
be in contact with their family and
tremendous toll on these nurses on the
doctors on the people on the front line
so people who you know want to criticize
measures like
worry mask and basic things that we know
absolutely no
work you know they should go talk to
those front line health people because i
think when they listen to them it's
pretty
clear we have to do whatever we can to
slow this virus down
you also called it foolishness i will
note governor mike dewine that's
ridiculous
thank you ridiculousness thank you yeah
synonym thank you very much we
appreciate it governor dewine